Khloe Kardashian has been by Lamar Odom  side throughout his recovery even  putting a halt on their divorce  proceedings now that she has split from  James Hardin are Khloe and Lamar getting  back together well et found out what  Kris Jenner is pulling for these are a  part of you that is hoping maybe that  they can somehow rekindle I think it's  no secret that that's probably you know  that's probably right out there written  across my forehead or something but I  mean it you know I always want my kids  to have a happy ending all of them and I  consider Lamar he's one of my kids so I  fall in love with anybody my kids you  know bring to me and and we have as part  of our family they'll always be family  so I always want there to be a happy  ending